let's go to the tea what do you think
Nina last night it was fun to meet up
with them let's see on the cruise
friends okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to day eight of our European
adventure today we are in Qatar
Montenegro feeling a little bit better
just waking up and got up at 6 a.m.
[Music]
Montenegro this Couture about Vanessa
okay Couture what the Qatar I don't know
another UNESCO protected world site Game
of Thrones is shot here and my team is
here so Christina my video editor her
husband they do all the video editing
for for this channel and three other
people by my team are coming from Serbia
and we're gonna meet up and spend the
day one thing I've never met them
so I'm Christina I don't know how many
years years working with me you know I
always get it wrong because I don't want
to embarrass myself and just gonna get
10 drippy it's been a long time and this
person we're gonna meet face to face
besides just having Skype calls it's I'm
pretty excited
now before getting off Nina made a huge
mistake and lots of my having he like he
is it may be some fighting years okay
it's my huge mistake
just a big mistake I have no you know
sup my fault at all no possibility for
this lets have to get a new capping key
and then maybe get some food and then
and then leave get off the boat yeah
[Music]
okay enough the boat
where we going to put our fire going to
meet Aaron and Mina
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they are there's a team this team Oh
Christina's filming this is very meta
we're filming each other it's Christina
we made it we made it we made it
everybody's got cameras out what's up
man what's up what's up I'm good again
pushing you in you guys are all in the
flock down
[Music]
then we get Christina walking up the
stairs but we have all these videos of
Nina up and down the stairs on the
cruise ship looks like we're gonna eat
Nina's hungry
Nina's hungry
we've only seen Nina eat so far so we
need Christina eating now and thumbs up
we've been doing this thumbs up thumbs
up alright
you look a try it you're on camera
nice no I'll eat I haven't oh wait what
did you get that chicken
oh no squid with with hey I'm on top I'm
not used to sitting next to Nina here
usually rash we don't know it's pork is
it good
okay but dry all right okay Sam eat up
omelette squid okay try Nina I was Amina
so Sam and Kristina do salsa dancing
here as well he's gonna put some music
on
he'll kind of moves we've got right here
we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we're getting back on the boat the
Balkan team team Balkan say goodbye
we'll see you soon we'll see you soon
all right
hit the boat there's the team they're
waving
they're waving that was awesome Nina
what do you think Hey look as may not
the wall
this is Luca couture what do you think
Nina yeah so Sam and Cristina do my
video editing Ivan does all the research
for the videos luca does all the
comments and the channel anna does some
work for toronto dance salsa
she's Lucas fiancee doesn't work for the
ICI bleep nation team but we had to
bring her along doesn't show love to her
too and then who else is there
Eric was the son of Sam and Christina
and then they brought their dad I've
been looking but the dad along for the
trip as well so really awesome to meet
them face to face
it just felt normal yeah Christina was
feeling a little anxious apparently
before this just excited we've connected
so many times on skype and hangouts and
meeting online never in person it was
fun filled normal it was awesome we got
to do this more often
here do this more often next time we
would a Lexus Asia see the Asian team
we've got a team of what ivory six
people in the Philippines to see them to
come back and do Serbia Belgrade
anyway I'm super glad we did it they're
still there they're still there waving
team Balkan believe team balkon right
there the superfans bye guys
believe
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay a quick update Nina passed out for
a couple hours just feeling seasick and
dizzy a little bit in Montenegro so she
came upstairs and passed out I eat a lot
of ice cream I had two scoops of ice
cream in Montenegro then I came up and
had two Ice Cream Sandwich bars that I
had two more scoops of ice cream here as
six ice creams okay and then I had the
Pina Colada non-alcoholic mix this has
been a lot of sweet stuff which did not
help my cough yeah but whatever whatever
last day friends last day on the cruise
friends right okay okay dinner
and then have to pack up and Nina
brought her shoes just in case is
dancing no no it's sooo boring vain not
the light in vain does the interpreters
shoes that's why we love you Nina last
dinner last dinner on the boat Nina this
is it
[Music]
alright alright not bad we'll take it
today custard
she's not happy last dessert on the boat
oh I think it's still the barn music
it's still the boring music
no more Latin dancing for us
[Music]
we are all packed up pretty much just as
soon as I get out of this keep packing
away ready to go back to Toronto
hey the wife's back there how you doing
life good good you know no it's cute we
love you
you know once a hit at the buffet one
last time last night on the boat got to
do it right and you know we're gonna
have ice cream no pizza
fruit noodles let's go see look at
what's on CNN oh it just missed it
they said rare hurricane piling the
Mediterranean that was what we suffered
through I feel bad the Medicaid strikes
Greece the Medicaid see rare
hurricane-like storm bodies minute
disparate see look at that chaos that's
what we were that's that's why I was so
crazy the up and down those insane
anyway we're out we're out of the
craziness now it's just it's just mildly
going up and down but of course Nina and
I bring the rare it's because we bring
such positivity that's because we're so
awesome but nature needs to
counterbalance it with some chaos what
do you think we bring so much sunlight
that Nature has to bring the clouds just
just to balance it out what do you think
is that is that legit what do you guys
think is that legit tell a JIT switch it
okay
buff a time
[Music]
all right we are headed back to our
cabin for our last night on the boat you
guys are now knighted to that but if you
want to see what we did yesterday on the
beautiful Greek island of Corfu check
out the video right next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to and we'll
see you there
you don't look that excited Wow
when you hold hands with need I'd be
prepared to have your hand squeeze